la voix c'est ce qui porte les motions
de l'orateur
ce qui intéresse le public et même mon
adversaire ce n'est pas les mots que je
dis c'est la sensation que j'ai en les
vocalises
[Musique]
les erreurs à ne pas commettre
son classique
et verture nous de démarrer et de
débattre sans notes attention les notes
sont une sécurité mais je ne dirai
jamais à quelqu'un qui est incapable de
regarder de se tenir et de vocalises et
correctement ne prend pas de notes parce
que n'étant pas un bon orateur il va se
perdre dans les notes ne sont qu'un
pis-aller
il ya une stratégie qui consiste à
laisser des marais l'autre d'abord et
d'arrivée ensuite avec son épée et dans
le dos quand le voilà c'est formidable
on est resté à couvert il s'est mis à
découvert et jeu ça c'est le grand rêve
de la plupart des orateurs pris par le
trac pour un bon orateur démarrer le
premier ou le second n'a aucune
importance si je démarre le 1er il faut
que je crée une belle parole un bon
confort d écoute pour orienter le débat
est flatté l'écoutent de celui que j'ai
en face de moi qui est un public avant
d'être un adversaire et en tant que
public il va me légitimé dans ce que
j'ai dit parce que j'ai été un orateur
légitime à son égard dans les canons de
l'art oratoire et puis si je démarre en
2d il faut que je sois dans un débat
contradictoire meilleur que le premier
pour que pour le tiers extérieurs qui le
public mon idée l'emportent dans son
souvenir sur l'idée de mon adversaire
[Musique]
les grands orateurs savent en coupant en
arrêtant la parole de l'autre un bon
débatteur c'est donner envie à l'autre
de s'arrêter de parler pour écouter et
non pas donner à l'autre le sentiment
qu'on lui coupe la parole
si je suis avec une voie correcte avec
un maintien correct et j'emploie les
mots qu'il faut je pourrais arrêter la
parole de l'autre et avec plaisir il
s'arrêtera en france on dit il ne faut
pas couper la parole c'est mal élevé il
est vrai que la plupart des gens qu'ils
font sachant que c'est mal élevé le font
mal culpabiliser et par conséquent
n'étant pas des orateurs à la hauteur ne
peuvent pas couper la parole mais c'est
une erreur de penser qu'on ne peut pas
couper la parole